- All right, everybody,
let's close this story
sure to make you feel warm
and fuzzy this holiday season,
this is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
So when a North Carolina 7-year-old
told her dad she wanted
to start a coffee company,
he went all in to help her out.
Now, two years later, she
is one of the youngest CEOs
I have ever heard of.
She has a thriving coffee shop
and an online business
selling home roasted beans
and candles and soap
made from coffee grounds,
all that, and she and
her dad are giving back
to the community, which is incredible.
We have her on the line right now
along with her father watching on WYFF4.
What's up Charlie and TJ?
(audience cheering)
- Hey, Kelly!
- Hello, so Charlie,
what's it like being CEO?
You're so young.
- I love it
because everybody supports me
and whenever me and dad do,
it's never one single person.
Everything we do, we work together to do.
- Aw, that's incredibly
cool for your family.
So TJ, what is it like
working with her like this?
- I've never seen anything into comparison
of watching the people that come in
and support her within this
town and this community.
It's absolutely amazing.
It's literally the epitome
of the perfection of life
of being a dad.
- Aw!
Oh my gosh and also, you're
killing me, I'm gonna cry.
Also, what I think is
really cool is you're
you're having this
beautiful family moment,
but you're giving back to
the community as well, right?
- Yeah, our goal this year is
to help over a thousand kids
within the community.
So we're taking a portion of our proceeds
Charlie came up with to
give at least a portion
of the coffee that we saw
online and within our stores
to help support these kids
so that way we can make sure
that they get toys this year.
- Because it's just fair for kids
not to get at least one toy.
- That's right and I've
been homeless before
and been through some pretty tough times
and I know what it's like to struggle
and we wanna make sure that those kids
don't have that problem this year.
- Oh, wow!
What a beautiful family!
Thank you, Charlie, Thank you TJ,
I'm liking your posts right now.
(bell dinging)
- Yes ma'am. Thank you.
- All right, well that's not all.
You're cute, little,
"Yes ma'am," I like it.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor truly unstoppable people
just like the two of you.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for $1,000 to help you provide more kids
with more toys for the holidays.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you, Kelly.
- Have such a great night y'all
and thank you all our guests this hour.
Hannah Waddingham, Nikki
Garcia and Brie Garcia,
Addy, Yamika, Alex for
joining us, Lawrence Zarian
and Odaya the elf and Katie Kadan as well.
Y'all have a great day and if
it's not, try and change it.